the president attacked San Juan mayor
suggesting Democrats were telling her to
be quote nasty to trump the president is
doing the best he can
[Music]
we've got to be supporting our president
right now it's a it's a tough time so
everybody wanted to do our part we've
sort of written a stirring ballot yes
tweet your love what is what is it we
are the world without so many cooks
Beyonce said no but I mean Kelly said no
Michelle's a maybe yeah so the Aaron
Carter has said he'll he's thinking
about it yeah I think he's you know he's
in and out of jail three doors down is
begging us to do it yeah but it's so
it's like it's a bad piano guys one in
my thing is what many keyboards will
overpower the track exactly and it's
sort of all they do it's more of a horn
songs
it's very Gloria Estefan's the Rockettes
have agreed the only half of them yeah I
won't hear them they'll just be kicking
in the back around Tila Tequila is a big
we loved her a lot of people don't know
her music career but she I mean she's
got a I love I the DJ Oh Hulk
Hogan yeah Logan yeah Hulk Hogan is
gonna be really good because he plays
violin actually is that true yes and
there's sort of an orchestral suite in
the middle of the song we wrote a rap
for Colton yeah she's sort of the
essence of hip-hop we wanted to feel
like a right-wing stomp at points
weren't sort of like found instruments
because honestly can we say stomp is so
leftist stop is so leftist again they're
like stop well it pushes a recycling
agenda I'll say this right now on the
air we don't have as much strong vocal
you know right people who really have
the rain but kind of range the aaron and
i have frankly we don't have a lot of we
have an elastic range five octaves like
Mariah yeah
five six on a cold day